according to Tyson Fury he trained 12
weeks for this that's coming out of his
mouth his exact words were oh I'm I'm
taking him as serious as I can I train
12 weeks just like anybody he's a big
strong powerful dude I'm not overlooking
anybody and even before this every Joe
Schmo that had a freaking mic went up to
him goes I know that you're doing this
and you know Tyson's a big powerful guy
but usk this is a tuneup fight to get
ready for usyk and what Fury say I'm not
looking past anybody man I did 12 weeks
of Camp those are the words coming out
of his mouth those were his exact words
so I'm going to believe him on that now
did he look like the same fighter that
fought Wilder no but according to his
entire camp and anybody that knows Tyson
they said we prepared 12 weeks for the
best version of Francis zanu here's the
problem with that they didn't realize
how damn good Francis andano was at
boxing